[Musique]
bonsoir à tous et bienvenue dans point
de vue ravi de vous retrouver chers
internautes est ravi de retrouver aussi
deux invités de talent bon ce soir
mathieu soupière vous êtes consultant
expert associé à la fondation jean
jaurès
vous avez aussi conseillé mais rien
belle connerie quand elle était ministre
du travail
pendant le quinquennat de françois
hollande et bonsoir jérôme sainte marie
françois politologues sondeurs président
fondateur de la société pôle inbox est
votre dernier ouvrage bloc contre bloc
la dynamique du maquereau nice n'a été
publié aux éditions du cerf
peut-être avez-vous veiller tard hier
soir chers internautes pour suivre le
débat le premier débat de la campagne
présidentielle entre donald trump et joe
biden et si vous étiez coucher et bien
voici à peu près ce que ça a donné
beaucoup moins que ce que pour eux nous
devons aller au bout me calmer
alors je dois vous dire que matthias
chouquer jobson mari en plus souri à aux
propos de donald trump qu'à ceux de joe
biden mais globalement matière que ce
débat c'était quoi c'était le reflet de
la société politique américaine ou juste
un naufrage alors c'est le dilemme quand
on est confronté à donald trump
on a envie d'être effondrée évidemment
parce qu'il s'agit de choses sérieuses
et il ya quand même toujours une petite
dimension un peu mel brooks ont
l'impression d'être dans un film dans
une forme de parodies malheureusement
c'est la vraie démocratie
d'abord il ya surtout sûrement pas de
complexe de supériorité à nourrir
vis-à-vis des etats-unis quand on voit
parfois ce qu'est la vie politique chez
nous il faut être tout à fait modeste
bon heureusement on n'atteint pas quand
même les sommets auxquels nous nous
invite dans le trump sais pas si c'est
une défaite de la politique je me mets à
la place d'un des batteurs face à donald
trump
c'est probable ont très compliqué alors
la politique est devenue une science
tout à fait complexe la gestion des
affaires collectives est désormais
quelque chose de très difficile
néanmoins quand vous êtes face à donald
trump la chose est encore plus complexe
puisque on sait qu'il a un rapport à la
politique à la démocratie et plus
fondamentalement à la vérité qui est
tout à fait singulier donc quand vous
avez en face de vous un des batteurs qui
n'est pas seulement un des batteurs qui
est le président sortant qui manie
depuis quatre ans la réalité avec une
forme de fantaisie et même avec une
forme de malhonnêteté
c'est toujours très difficile de
débattre voilà voilà au moins pour
l'entrée en matière marie c'est de ces
deux hommes ils ceux qui se balancent
des grenades et chacun son tour
comme s'ils vivaient dans deux mondes
qui était si différents que qui ne
pouvaient plus dialoguer entre eux des
frappant c'est de voir que c'était le
ton très méprisant finalement pour la
personne même de l'adversaire et des
deux côtés
même le monde qui est pas spécialement
hostiles à aux démocrates américains
seulement confiseurs et bien remarque
c'est des propos de bistrot crois que la
pression est encore plus dur qu'ils
utilisent pour qualifier la manière dont
s'est exprimé joe biden donc si vous
voulez faux pas je signe après on aime
ou on aime pas beaucoup trop en france
mais je crois que
malheureusement il y avait au niveau
stylistique qui avait une certaine
égalité entre les entre les deux hommes
par ailleurs parce qu'il me frappe quand
j'écoute et confrères les commentaires
on retrouve ça vous avez plein de pays
où le système politique a changé
il y avait une opposition gauche droite
et puis maintenant c'est d'autre chose
je prends cas l'italie par exemple on
peut prendre lequel la france en grande
partie également aux états unis ce qui
s'est produit ces derniers temps c'est
qu'en fait le système en apparence le
système politique est restée identique
on a bien à parti conservateur est un
parti démocrate parti républicain pardon
enfin conservateur en l'occurrence mais
ça c'est plutôt à l'autre c'est en
grande bretagne où il y avait un peu le
même phénomène et le parti conservateur
le parti républicain et le parti
démocrate que l'on a tendance en france
de manière assez rooney depuis toujours
mais tant pis assimiler la droite
l'autre à la gauche
c'est très très content et ça a toujours
été très contestable alors maintenant
c'est plus est ça n'a plus rien à voir
c'est à dire qu'effectivement vous avez
aujourd'hui un parti des progressistes
au sens quasiment ma chronique du terme
c'est jazz band joe biden un parti
populiste qui s'intéressent quand même à
la condition de la classe ouvrière
américaine pardon de manière assez
intéressante les critiques sur la russie
pour la chine c'est des critiques on
l'est qui ont entraîné notamment au
problème du libre échange et ce parti
populiste c'est justement maintenant le
parti républicain dont vous avez eu en
quelque sorte une subversion du système
politique américain mais qui n'est pas
visible parce que ou pas trop visible
parce que les cadres partisans ont été
maintenus échanger et vous avez
exactement une couverture médiatique qui
dont le biais est classique
je parle des états unis aux états unis
même vous avez des grands médias
meanstream qui sont parfois que nous
vous et quelques autres mais qui sont
pour l'essentiel en titre impôts baii de
la même manière qu'eux en europe les
médias dominants mettant l'exception
bien sûr du figaro et bien sont
généralement très gentil populiste il
l'avait habillée dans le commentaire des
débats qui est absolument évident on est
là vous avez justement donc c'est ça qui
rend qui rend si vous des choses
compliquées et à mon avis très
conflictuel parce que vous avez
justement trump est attaqué de manière
extrêmement déloyale et lui-même attaque
de manière
des loyers je vous donne le point de vue
de nos internautes merci à vous tous qui
réagissait en direct à notre émission
d'abord notre petite consultation
express
pensez vous que ce débat était une forme
d'échec politique c'est à dire une forme
de défaite de la politique et du débat
la réponse est oui à 77%
voici quelques commentaires plutôt
critique celui de patrick sur youtube ce
débat c'était un tournoi d'injures rien
sur le fond où la politique intérieure
et extérieure de chacun dommage
voilà ce qui arrive ajoute karine
toujours sur youtube quand un candidat
de télé réalité devient président de la
première puissance mondiale
et puis jimmy sur lefigaro.fr qui
analyse des chose d'assez près en disant
que brydon a mal joué on se rabaissant
au jeu de trompe mais que m ajoute il
est un vrai clown qui a besoin du siège
pour se refaire financièrement du siège
c'est peut-être du ciel sans doute du
siège de président nadia sur youtube
c'est drôle mais quand rob débattez avec
clinton il l'était plus offensif
il appelle by dungeon endormi mais le
plus endormis des deux n'était pas celui
qu'on croit trump n'était pas sûr de lui
est ce que matthew soupière le niveau de
ce débat c'est de la responsabilité des
deux hommes qui s'affrontaient cette
nuit où est-ce que c'est pas la demande
qui fait l'offre c'est-à-dire que si les
américains n'étaient pas en demande de
ce genre d'affrontement peut-être qu'ils
ne le ferai pas parce que parce que ça
ferait des flop d'audience
alors ce qui est sûr c'est qu'il ya un
rapport à la politique un rapport à la
démocratie qui a changé un peu partout
ça vaut pour chez nous ça vaut pour un
certain nombre de pays européens et ça
vaut aussi aux états unis donc le
rapport le rapport à tout cela a modifié
pour vous répondre je rebondis sur ce
que disait jérôme et alors je partage
une partie de ce qu'il dit mais je
nuance d'autres choses d'abord il est
vrai que le clivage entre les
républicains et les démocrates aux états
unis ne recouvre pas ce qui est le
clivage assez classique et
traditionnelle chez nous entre la gauche
et la droite
néanmoins avec le programme que wheldon
a développé cette fois ci compte tenu
encore une fois de l'actualité
économique et social et sanitaire aux
états unis et des grands débats qui se
sont nouées autour de cette situation
très particulière il y a quand même un
retour de l'interventionnisme partout
chez nous en europe mais aussi aux états
unis et avec dans la plateforme
électorale des démocrates comme
quelque chose qui fleure bon ce que la
social démocratie européenne a longtemps
porté en forme encore une fois d'
interventionnisme public de travail sur
les inégalités et c'est donc donc ça
c'est de la division de fonds oui mais
c'est bien mais deux points de vue là de
ce point de vue là pardon mais on a
réinjecté de l'idéologie dans la
politique aux etats-unis sais pas si
c'est un retour arrière mais c'est
quelque chose de nouveau
la tendance avait été très forte avec
bernie sanders dont on a cru un moment
donné en fait qu'il allait être le
leader des démocrates aux usa sur le
fond est ce que sur la forme à votre
avis ce type de débat répond à la
nouvelle demande du peuple américain en
matière de débat politique lors de
remarques par rapport à cela je ne sais
pas si c'est une défaite de la politique
c'est assurément une défaite du jeunisme
là pour le coup vous avez deux candidats
qui incarne quand même l'élite masculine
blanche dans une séniorité très avancé
on avait eu avec l'élection d'obama
quand même une nouvelle figure de la
diversité à la maison blanche
on avait cru qu'avec barack obama pardon
hillary clinton
longtemps favorite allait être la
première femme à la maison blanche donc
diversité et puis ensuite mixité on a
considérablement reculé avec l'élection
de trump à travers le profil qui était
le sien et à travers le discours qu'il
portait et on voit bien que la dent dans
la confrontation avec joe joe biden les
choses ont évolué et ensuite je reviens
quand même sur ce que je disais je
le niveau du débat face à donald trump
alors encore une fois il est facile
d'accabler donald trump
mais il ya quand même une nouveauté jeu
jérôme avait raison de dire que
l'essentiel des médias mainstream était
évidemment pro by de nos états unis je
nuance la crème en disant que fox news
la chaîne de trump bénéficie d'une
audience considérable et que les réseaux
sociaux aujourd'hui constitue une trame
d'information de véhicules d'information
pour l'ensemble de la population qui là
est plutôt favorable encore une fois à
au discours populiste républicain géré
les choses sont vraies cela complexe
parce que je ne dirais pas que mathieu
guerre il a totalement répondu peut-être
que ce débat c'est pas juste le niveau
14 des américains alors qu'il demande
vous imaginez bien j'étais pas
spécialement dans les coulisses du débat
aux états unis mais si on lit sur les
états unis je pense notamment un article
je lui en venant dans le monde
diplomatique qui va sortir d'octobre du
célèbre thomas frank qui est un
journaliste et vaguement sociologue je
crois américains qui avec
des livres qu'on est traduit en français
sous le nom de leurs pas du tout le
titre américain mais pourquoi les
pauvres votent à droite et ensuite
pourquoi elle est riche vote à gauche
moi c'est très rigolo titres américains
c'est que les premiers que le kansas etc
bref dans ce grand article très
intéressant thomas franc qui souligne à
quel point le climat politique américain
bien avant cette émission s'est dégradé
à quel point il ya une impression de on
mime quasiment la guerre civile enfin
gers et il ya des violences dans les
rues ce qui est très rare aux états unis
c'est pas un pays où manifestent
beaucoup par ailleurs il ya des milices
armées qui vont qui rentre dans les
dents les les capitales provinciaux il
ya une mine histoire en sens inverse
volet qui veulent qu'il balade telle une
véritable armée c'est très surprenant
dans tout le monde est armé donc
forcément ça fait des belles images mais
c'est il ya une haine réciproque très
très forte il me semble que c'est une
réciproque est sien comme un petit peu
comme dans d'autres c'est un peu mon
bouquin bloc contre bloc sur la france
tient au fait que ce réveil des conflits
qui sont des conflits d'intérêts de
classe ou en tout cas de deux groupes
qui n'ont plus rien à se dire
c'est à dire et qui donc quand on n'a
plus rien à dire on s'insulte c'est à
dire que c'est il ya des problèmes
ethniques
c'est assez évident il ya des problèmes
culturels c'est à dire qu'effectivement
d'un côté il sait ce que madame clinton
appelait peu judicieusement les
déplorables
c'est à dire est ce qu'on appelle aussi
parfois il ya un autre auteur qui parle
des bacs rockit c'est à dire de ceux qui
sont dans les bons arrières a de
mauvaises élèves sans barrière puis elle
efface rauque et ce qu'ils veulent ce
sont les bons élèves les mauvais élèves
du côté de train pour les bons élèves
dire ce qu'on ait diplôme c'est du côté
de joe biden tout ça nous rappelle
quelque chose
vous voyez il ya également l'amérique
périphériques si j'ose dire pour
reprendre la série lui le maire
périphériques celle qui est en réalité
au centre de la carte elle-même des
grandes plaines
elle s'oppose à
à l'amérique de la côte ouest et de la
côte est des grandes métropoles
là aussi on connaît cette histoire c'est
partout pareil
il ya les gagnants de la mondialisation
il ya les perdants de la mondialisation
est ce que vous avez à heath cob
rarement si vous voulez dans l'histoire
américaine
est ce que vous aviez que dans le débat
fasse emmanuel macron marine le pen
faisait du trump c'est à dire et
n'essayez pas de débattre mais mais
balancer des vannes
il y avait un point commun si vous
voulez c'était le fait qu'il y avait ils
ont abordé le débat dans une logique de
rupture dans l'idée que la faiblesse
caractériel supposée de l'adversaire
pouvait permettre un effondrement un
effondrement presque psychologiques
physiques et que donc il fallait assumer
un certain niveau de véhémence on va
dire ça publiquement de manière à ce que
l'adversaire supposé faible s'effondre
c'est une stratégie qui est évidemment
très facile à contrer on a bien vu que
joe biden comme emmanuel macron si j'ose
dire ont joué en fond de court et ont
laissé s'épuiser l'adversaire je voulais
compléter ce que disait jérôme justement
sur le les clivages dans dans la société
on a probablement effectivement la même
chose ou un parallélisme à faire entre
la situation française et la situation
américaine
pour illustrer ce que disait jérôme 80%
des électeurs républicains pensent que
les socialistes ont pris le pouvoir chez
les démocrates
et en face 82% des démocrates pensent
que les racistes ont pris le pouvoir
chez les républicains
donc il ya évidemment une part de
fantasme dans ces réalités différentes
mais où est le commun c'est-à-dire qu'on
voit bien qu'on a deux réalités
totalement parallèle est totalement
disjointes dire que la problématique du
commun a recréé était probablement une
problématique centrale
merci à nos internautes de continuer à
nous enrichir de leurs commentaires à
kevin sur youtube on sent que tout ce
qui intéresse trump c'est gagner du
temps en boycottant les élections
christophe sur lefigaro.fr qui considère
que les commentateurs et y met des
guillemets français mais pas forcément
ceux de votre plateau ajoutent ils ont
souvent un biais l'analyse négatif
envers trt et puis babineau qui conclut
en disant qu'il ne faut pas oublier que
la crise du coronavirus à endommager
l'image de donald trump
on va voir
si les prochains sondages démontrent ou
non que ce débat a fait bouger les
lignes
la première puissance économique
mondiale quand même et celle qui
démontre sa plus grande faiblesse face
au co vide c'est quand même saisissant
alors est ce que c'est parce que un
populiste au pouvoir fait la
démonstration de son incompétence
on peut être frappé de voir que les
trois grands pays riches qui ont
beaucoup de mal face au co vide ce sont
les etats-unis le brésil et l'angleterre
point commun effectivement il y à la
tête de ces pays là des dirigeants qu'on
peut au moins partiellement qualifié de
populiste
est ce parce que le populiste et
beaucoup beaucoup dans le fantasme bien
souvent dans le fantasme et dans la
construction d'une offre politique qui
repose sur le fantasme et que la
confrontation
au fait à l'épreuve des faits et en a
été une épreuve de vérité je ne sais pas
mais c'est quand même troublant et je
reviens sur ce qu'on disait tout à
l'heure sur le point commun entre entre
trump et et marine le pen
oui le fantasme et le mensonge font
partie des ingrédients qui permettent à
à deux personnalités politiques de ce
type en fait de prospérer et le web
quand les démocrates le métier de
manière véhémente et répétés sur
l'histoire du rugby gate l ordre à
accuser les russes de tout contrôler et
c'est cette histoire c'est totalement 17
aces notamment détruites les démocrates
ont menti de manière invraisemblable
les démocrates ont essayé ce qui est
quand même pas très dévaluée ce qui est
pas très républicain on va dire ou pas
très démocratique pas comment je dois
dire finie ils ont essayé au début de
l'année de d'obtenir la destitution du
président entre un peu c'est pas quelque
chose si vous voulez qui aurait été fait
imaginer l inverse si l'on accusé d
ensemble compact un autre sujet quitte
aussi bertrand je vous assure sur la
démo il n'y a pas de monopole en fait du
mensonge chez les républicains
mais encore une fois le washington post
a fait une étude sur les mensonges du
président trump 20000 mensonges ont été
recensés en moyenne une cinquantaine par
jour
relayée sur les réseaux sociaux et ça
c'est ça devrait interpeller n'importe
quel politologues sont en nouveauté
quand même dans l'exercice de la
démocratie aujourd'hui maire ce point
vous parlez de l'exercice de la
démocratie en voici un autre celui des
conventions citoyenne le premier
ministre jean castex recevait
aujourd'hui une délégation de la
convention citoyenne pour le climat vous
avez cette réunion de 5 250 français qui
ont été sur la base du volontariat
réunis pendant plusieurs mois au conseil
économique et social soit conduit
environnemental c'est maintenant et pour
faire des propositions pour lutter
contre le réchauffement climatique à
l'argent caste exigeait une trentaine de
propositions qu'on trouvait des suites
favorables pour les autres on va voir
dit il
certains se souviennent que par exemple
la demande d'un moratoire sur la 5g a
été écartée par le gouvernement mais je
voudrais qu'on s'arrête quelques minutes
sur cette façon c'est de nouveau mode
démocratique qui consiste à tirer au
sort des citoyens pour leur demander
leur avis il ya une autre expérience de
ce type qui s'est passé pour la
politique agricole française notamment
la politique agricole commune
et le moins qu'on puisse dire c'est que
ça n'a pas enchanté la patronne de la
fnsea le principal syndicat agricole
christiane lambert quand parle de
l'agriculture et qu'on dialogue oui par
contre quand je vois que 134 personnes
tirées au sort était réuni ce week-end
pour parler de la pac et que je connais
la complexité de la pac
j'ai vu aussi comment la convention
citoyenne a opéré quelques raccourcis
sur les sujets agricoles
donc moi je suis attaché à la démocratie
représentative et l'a tiré des gens au
sort qu'ils ont fait connaissance et
leur faire parler de la pac beaucoup
d'agriculteurs le vivent très mal que
c'est une façon de contourner les
représentants alors consulté oui donné
pouvoir de décision et en disant je
prends les 146 mesure de la convention
citoyenne ça m'inquiète
l'écorégion citoyenne c'est un progrès
démocratique ou une régression
formidable régression alors ça se sait
et c'est absolument évident dire que
c'est ça vient d'une technique qui était
très longtemps développé par les
instituts de sondage et défendu par
quelques sociologues éminents comme
monsieur bois son prénom m'échapper le
hic blondieau actuellement sans aucune
beaucoup qui est de ne réunir d'un côté
des experts de l'autre côté des profanes
et puis d'essayer de voir comment on
peut construire un discours démocratique
avec la parole d'expertisé la parole du
citoyen lambda
c'était donc très développées sur des
problématiques comme le nucléaire comme
la commune image comme la santé publique
etc
comment arriver à discours commun mais
ce n'est pas pour la prise de décision
c'est essentiellement en fait pour la
communication
comment essayer de se comprendre ça
s'était très bien maintenant en faire un
instrument démocratique c'est très
compliqué alors là dessus il ya eu un
excellent une excellente tribune qui
était publié dans l'excellent en figaro
je crois peut-être figaro box par le
nombre d'accès lan a fait don qui avait
qui a écrit sur les origines antiques de
du tirage au sort contraire ment il le
démontre très bien là des prises de
décision démocratique à la tène par
exemple ne se faisait pas partie rage au
sort ce qu'il faisait c'était le choix
des fonctionnaires en quelque sorte
enfin des proto fonctionnaires qui veut
se dire chargé d'encadrer justement les
débats mais vous n'avez pas l'idée que
l'on pourrait se passer d'un mirage du
peuple rassemblé et c'est une idée très
très très contestable mais je laisse ce
mathieu développer permettre sous qu'il
ya effectivement la fin de ces gens sont
pas élus donc ils n'ont pas de
légitimité démocratique
et puis ce qu'il faut dire aussi c'est
que c'est pas comme un jury d'assises où
on est obligé d'aller
c'est sur la base du volontariat et
d'après ce que j'ai compris il ya des
milliers de français qui ont été
contacté pour faire partie de cette
convention citoyenne sur le climat tous
ceux qui s'intéressent et par la
question répondu non et du coup ne sont
venus que les militants écologistes qui
ont fait un programme radical
alors on peut pointer les faiblesses de
son père est ce que je dis c'est à ces
meurtres est à ses rangs si je sais pas
dans quelle mesure ces ça fait preuve de
nuance je jouais pour aller vite aussi
pour aller vite on peut tout à fait
contester les faiblesses et les travers
de ce genre de dispositif je n'arrive
pas pour autant comme comme jérôme à
avoir en cela une régression au
contraire c'est à dire que on a un sujet
avec la démocratie représentative
la démocratie représentative elle est en
crise tous les indicateurs le démontre
depuis les taux d'abstention qui ne
cesse d'augmenter au fait qu' on déserte
et partis politiques on déserte les
corps intermédiaires on ne s'y intéresse
plus pire qu'on a plus du tout confiance
en nos élites démocratique on considère
qu'elle ne nous représentent plus on
considère qu'elles sont six français sur
dix considèrent qu'elles sont corrompus
sept français sur dix considèrent qu'ils
ne sont plus bien représentée par les
représentants politiques l'échelon du
maire encore s'en sort pas trop mal mais
dès qu'on s'éloigne de la proximité
comme ça en fait
la défiance augmente on a un vrai sujet
de ce point de vue là au point même que
les trois quarts des français pensaient
que la démocratie était le meilleur
système possible
il y a encore quelques années ils ne
sont plus que deux tiers donc il y a un
enjeu autour autour de la question
démocratique et par ailleurs non
seulement je pense que je fais partie
des deux tiers des français qui pensent
que la démocratie est le meilleur
système possible mais précisément c'est
un système qui se veut perfectible qui
considèrent qu'il est en permanence
inachevé et qu'il a vocation à
progresser que la démocratie parfaite ça
n'existe pas et qu'on doit acheminer
pour encore une fois améliorer les
choses
les dispositifs de démocratie dit
participative précisément viennent
compléter sa il s'agit pas du tout dire
que la démocratie participative vient se
substituer
et quant à la démocratie leurs prêts
l'an passé d'ailleurs quand manuel
maquereau a dit je reprendrai tel quel
les préconisations de la convention
citoyenne sur le climat là vous êtes
d'accord que c'était quand même une
forme de sophrologie sont
antidémocratiques nos lauriers l'a pas
fait mais non pardon mais lui est
légitime à le dire lui précisément il
est totalement légitime --donc ci lui
légitimement élus décident que le
dispositif loup type démocratie
participative dont il se sert pour avoir
non seulement des idées mais une forme
de plateforme consensuelle
si lui estime que c'est le bon outil
pour ensuite prendre des
sion ça le regarde évidemment ce qui
serait absurde c'est ce que tu absurde
c'est de tirer des gens au sort et de
considérer que subitement les décisions
arrêtées par ce collectif
peu importe qui pèse dix ou cent
cinquante personnes s'impose à
l'ensemble de la collectivité
ça ça ne tient pas la route mais
personne n'évoque les choses sous cet
angle à la démocratie participative à
l'échelon local
elle existe en fait depuis très
longtemps il ya des conseils d'anciens
il ya des conseils de la jeunesse il ya
des conseils de quartier dans les lycées
il ya des conseils de vie lycéenne
dans l'entreprise on parle de démocratie
sociale évidemment avec des irp et non
mais la démocratie elle existe
absolument parler on vous a entendu je
donne juste la parole aux internautes
puis après je continue mon cher j'ai
envie
question emmanuel macron doit-il
appliquer les recommandations de la
convention climat c'est là c'est la
question du jour
et bien c'est non à 64% et je vous livre
cette réaction de christophe sur
lefigaro.fr
si on veut une belle convention
citoyenne ayant recours au référendum
audio absolument c'est tout à fait ce
que je voulais développer
non mais j'aime beaucoup aussi la
démocratie est sûre pour ça je trouve
que c'est un peu dommage de galvauder le
terme
quand on entend par exemple démocratie
d'entreprise c'est une fête à social
c'est un oxymore 5 6 morts ça ne peut
pas exister ça n'existe pas dire donc
vous avez ensuite d'évoquer cette forme
démocratie parle par exemple ceux dont
on parle le tirage au sort etc
c'est une démocratie où il manque deux
choses s'ils veulent se dire le demos et
le kratos c'est pas le peuple
c'est pas le peuple le peuple il n'est
pas tirée au sort c'est le peuple c'est
ça en grès noah cette pub gratos et le
pouvoir
donc il y manque à la fois on sait pas
de qui on parle de gens tirent au sort
qui comme vous l'avez dit peut-être sont
venus peut-être pas sont pas venus et
cetera c'est pas le peuple souverain
et surtout il ya pas de kratos il n'y a
pas le pouvoir une des raisons
évidemment lit les sondages que je fais
et puis mon dieu que publie la fondation
jean jaurès mais vous avez effectivement
la défiance par rapport à nos élites
politiques on va dire ça tout simplement
nos représentants politiques un soyez
c'est aussi le sentiment qu'ils n'ont
plus le pouvoir c'est à dire qu'on va
passer qu'ils conservent des avantages
liés à leur fonction que les français
sur estime grandement d'ailleurs mais et
quand en face ils n'ont pas un pouvoir
réel leur permettrait d'agir au service
des citoyens
donc effectivement on dévitalise les
structures réellement représentative au
profit en bas de formules de
communication en fait qu'ils sont par
exemple cette convention comme le grand
débat national c'est un peu la même
chose également des structures ou
essentiellement c'est de la com est ce
que ces gens qui participent loyalement
durant ces 150 personnes 200 personnes
qui m'a fait loyalement à ces débats à
la fin il donne un avis purement
consultatif et puis le président va
choisir ce qui m'intéresse c'est ce qui
les intéresse pas et le foie à partir de
dossier préparé par des experts
donc les malheureuses a appelé dindon de
la farce quand même d'ailleurs
consulter ensuite et ensuite vous avez
effectivement c'est tout le contraire de
ce qu'on appelle le référendum dans le
référendum vous avez le débat c'est le
peuple qui décide et le crac au sens
précis c'est de pouvoir depuis 2005
depuis 2005 on sait qu elle l usage qui
et quel respect bien sûr mathieu parler
de la déception de
deux des participants à ce type
d'instance quand il voit que toutes les
recommandations sont pas appliquées
écoutez ce qui ressemble un peu à des
états d'âme ce de grégoire pratique il
est justement membre de la convention
citoyenne sur le climat a toujours
quelques interrogations sur savoir ben
voilà oui c'est une période qui est
compliquée pour nous on sent que nos
mesures peuvent faire et qui a pas
forcément ullink gouvernementales qui se
dégage en revanche ne lâchera pas on
restera toujours autour de la table dans
un esprit de travail on arrive pas là
pour on n'est pas là pour adouber ce qui
va passer on n'est pas là non plus pour
déconstruire ce qui va être dit on ce qu
on se réjouira de ce qui passera mais on
sera là aussi pour dire ben voilà les
points qui ne sont pas pris en compte
mathieu soupière je ne vois pas en fait
en vertu de quoi il faudrait opposé les
deux encore une fois de la démocratie
participative qui ne vient pas se
substituer à la démocratie
représentative et le référendum
ce sont des outils qui à mon avis
peuvent se compléter de façon tout à
fait féconde
on a une opinion qui aujourd'hui et est
faite de gens qui n'ont jamais été aussi
éduquer l'opinion française n'a jamais
été aussi éduquer qu'aujourd'hui et
informer qu'aujourd'hui et par ailleurs
il ya un mouvement d'individualisme qui
fait que chacun revendique sa part sa
place sa possible l'expression sur un
peu tous les sujets on le voit bien
d'ailleurs aujourd'hui avec la crise
sanitaire qu'on traverse et la question
de la démocratie sanitaire comment est
ce qu'en fait on continue à avoir du
débat public de la confrontation de la
dispute au moment où doivent se prendre
des décisions qui sont complexes dans un
contexte sanitaire extrêmement difficile
c'est un vrai sujet la question de la
démocratie aujourd'hui de l'état
d'urgence sanitaire et de la démocratie
en face pour essayer de prendre les
bonnes décisions c'est-à-dire les
décisions les plus efficaces et celles
qui sont les plus facilement acceptée
par le corps social
c'est un vrai enjeu donc la démocratie
participative elle a une double vertu
par rapport à cela
elle permet en fait de partager les
questions et partageons des questions et
et recourant à l'intelligence collective
à l'intelligence de nos concitoyens qui
ne sont pas tous des abrutis des regards
en fait oui on a expertisé à plusieurs
tel sujet et on n'en attirait des idées
plutôt intéressante et deuxième élément
à mon avis deuxième vertu
le fait que ça permet de dire à un
instant t quel est le point de consensus
quels sont les points d'accord et les
points de désaccord et et 2 et de
favoriser l'acceptabilité sociale d'un
sujet ou du
mesure pourquoi s'en priver et encore
une fois il s'agit ni de remplacer la
démocratie représentative ni de dire que
le référendum n'est pas par ailleurs un
outil important
les gilets jaunes il y a un an ou un an
et demi quand ils manifestaient ils
demandaient la parole il considérait que
le pouvoir leur avaient été confisqués
dans une sémantique populiste quasiment
assumer mais il considérait que le
pouvoir leur avaient été confisqués et
il demandait de sortir d'une forme de
verticalité pour avoir un peu plus
d'horizontalité de débats de
participation en quoi considérons que
c'est il légitime et que de la
démocratie participative au plus près du
terrain
ça permet pour partie de répondre à cela
je ne fais pas de politique en disant ça
mais la réponse qui avait été donné par
le pouvoir à l'époque d'organiser un
grand débat national des états généraux
version 2000 2019
en quoi c'est une mauvaise chose à la
fin on ne suit pas toutes les
préconisations qui s'écrivent dans
toutes les mairies ou dans toutes les
préfectures et est meilleur on prend on
prend le pouls à un instant t
c'était une bonne chose ça permettait de
faire une campagne pour des préparer la
campagne européenne sans passer par les
comptes de campagne c'est pas de la
colle pas d'accord je ne suis pas comme
magicien utilité et pas de l'accord et
matt donner le pouls vous donner la
parole c'est pas de l'agglo mathieu zouk
r on est on a un problème sémantique qui
est important ce que vous venez de
décrire c'est exactement les conférences
de consensus
comment on prépare une décision
politique ou une communication politique
à travers comment puisque les l'idéal
d'une société n'est pas de s'affronter
ne passait pas les états unis
actuellement si vous voulez c'est quand
même que les gens comprennent et
acceptent la parole des experts les
experts tiennent compte des la volonté
des citoyens des consommateurs des
usagers et qu'on arrive à des solutions
qui ne braque pas les uns contre les
autres et qui soit bien acceptée par
l'opinion publique pour ça c'est quand
même l'idéal on n'est pas voilà et je
suis pas spécialement un amoureux du
conflit non plus mais ça c'est une
conférence de consensus
ce n'est pas le ce qui me gêne dans ce
vote dans la démocratie participative
c'est tout simplement le mot démocratie
en voudrais attirer votre attention sur
un an
quelque chose sur votre conclusion
chercheront voilà les missions est sûre
j'ai constaté qu'ils avaient deux partis
actuellement qui utilisent le tirage au
sort dans le fonctionnement interne
ces deux partis c'est la réponse est
prévu dans les statuts oussekine plus
précisément leur tient lieu de statut
c'est d'une part la république en marche
ou dans le conseil
la république en marge il avait une
partie des gens qui sont cooptés par les
élus et le reste c'est des trois pelés
sein des militants a demandé du temps
pour simplifier tirés au sort
de l'autre côté c'est la france a
soumises qui croient même pas que la
france a suggéré devant des statues mais
en fait qui est elle-même recours
beaucoup
et donc c'est bien c'est pas bien ce
sont les deux parties les moins
démocratiques de l'histoire de france
c'est à dire que le vous prenez le parti
communiste pour leur assemblée nationale
l air et c'est infiniment plus
démocratique parce que vous avez des
structures des gens qui militent qui
sont qui ampute gravissent une
hiérarchie france qui choisir des
carrières militante peuvent s'opposer du
coup à la parole venu d'en haut
dans dix classes et des structures qui
sont en réalité totalement populiste aux
bons mauvais sens du terme ce soit la
france a soumises ou lrm vous avez la
toute puissance du chef qui n'est non
pas rattraper mais accrue par le fait
justement qu'on tire au sort nous
d'homère sait si les processus
démocratiques organisées ce faire merci
chers jérôme sainte-marie merci chamakh
yusuke à merci aussi à tous les
internautes dont on n'a pas eu le temps
malheureusement de prendre les opinions
plutôt de les énoncer à l'antenne merci
à kriss kross à patin couffin et puis à
6 j'assure le figaro.fr quand même je
vous livre sa conviction
macron peut valider les résultats de
cette commission puisque les questions
étaient établis à l'avance nos
volontaires n'étant là que pour valider
les propositions mariage aura pas le
temps de discuter avec vous de ce
postulat mai
et nous aurons la grande joie de nous
retrouver demain pour un nouveau
rendez-vous de point de vue merci
beaucoup bonsoir
[Musique]